we're going to show you our super bowl
forecast while they've got a chance of
thunderstorms in tampa
we'll have beautiful sunshine today
we've got some breezy winds
great skies out there nice and clear
we're going to keep that sunshine
but those winds are keeping it feeling
extra cool temperatures are cooler this
morning than they were yesterday we're
back down in the 40s
pretty much valley wide 38 at mountains
edge and it's feeling cooler
where we have those northerly winds and
we've had 30 mile an hour wind gusts at
the airport boulder city as well as
laughlin 30 plus mile an hour winds
so it's 50 degrees in boulder city but i
didn't quite feel that good that warm
look at ely up the road 10 degrees tone
upon reno in the 20s
perump ur drop down to 39 so we
definitely have cooler temperatures
look at our weekend i'll get to our
forecast today but let's look at the
weekend
67 on saturday and near 70 degrees
with lots of sunshine clouds late in the
day we're looking at oh my gosh it's
gonna be a beautiful day
all right we've got a wind advisory
reissued for the lake and the river
areas 8 a.m to 6 p.m
that's where the strongest winds will be
and then we've got the cold fronts that
have passed to the east
and that's open the door for the big big
cool down i want to show you some
amazing video that's coming
out of italy this is a mount aetna
that's been erupting
actually for the last several days
they've been having some small
earthquakes
inside the crater the crater the volcano
and is
the magma and the lava is just exploding
there
uh nobody is injured or in the way of it
but man it's just making for spectacular
video
all right so we're looking at 61 degrees
today yesterday we were in the 70s
and we'll continue to warm up even more
as we get into the weekend
so today the coolest day for the next
eight we'll get clouds late sunday
partly cloudy skies monday
and that's really all i have to worry
about right now there's no rain in the
forecast as much as we need it
but we do have a lot of days of sunshine
and almost springlike weather enjoy